there's a competition in new orleans
there's not supposed to be a competition
in green bay it's just awkward in green
bay because of what happened last year
in the first round of the draft a first
round pick packaged with a fourth round
pick to move up to get not a high end
receiver to get a backup quarterback to
aaron rodgers so
when we last addressed the aaron rodgers
contract situation mike silver of nfl
media was suggesting that there was some
sort of restructuring maybe new contract
and you know if they were trying to work
something out it looks like the deadline
was yesterday because the day came and
went 6.8 million roster bonus paid to
aaron rodgers that they were looking to
create cap space
by converting that roster bonus to a
signing bonus they blew the window to do
it
and you know chris it's hard not to look
at this and wonder
do they want to avoid kicking the can
and creating a bigger
cap hit next year if they were to trade
him
and that's what would happen if you
would convert the vast majority of his
salary this year to a signing bonus and
push it into future years if you trade
him next year all that money comes
onto the cap at one time uh
bottom line packers want to continue
year to year i believe aaron rodgers
wants more certainty and a greater
commitment than that and so far he
hasn't gotten it and the fact that he
got 6.8 million yesterday as not part of
a new contract
tells me that
he's farther away from getting that
contract than he was before the money
was paid yeah i mean listen it
it does seem fishy there's no doubt
about it i mean you look at it you look
the way his contract set up i mean next
year they they could get out of it yeah
they're going to take a you know a good
if they had to trade them you know like
you said i don't know the post june 1st
type of stuff there's going to be a dead
money of 17.2 million you know they can
split that in half teams can deal with
that you know where the cap is you know
probably projected to be for next year
so i do find it curious i really do
um but
where i think it's you know again not
going to be in the advantage of the
packers in their front office is just
i just think there's
there's just no way erin rogers doesn't
play awesome this year i just there's no
way i i don't i don't see it i think
he's totally comfortable in the offense
i think him and matt lefleur have a real
connection there i think nate hackett is
involved in that the offensive
coordinator slash quarterback coach
who's a rising star in the ranks too you
know i think there's something special
with these three and again i'm gonna go
back to what matt lefleur said the day
after the game or was the day of the
game when he almost broke down in tears
to go like
he's the heart and soul of our team
he is the guy he's 12. he's ar he's
a-rod whatever the hell you want to call
him he is the freaking man and i think
that's where
you know the front office is in a little
bit of a disconnect here with it and i
just again if rogers
how are they going to sell that to their
fan base next year maybe he sells it to
them going like screw you guys you don't
want to make a commitment i'm out of
here i don't know where this goes but
i'm with you it is a little curious with
how this was handled
three quick observations first of all if
they had maximized the ability to take
his compensation for this year
add it up signing bone not signing bonus
but base salary of 14.7 roster bonus of
6.8 you make the minimum salary of 1.075
you turn the rest of it into a signing
bonus you add a couple avoidable years
on the contract to get the maximum
spread if they had done all that to get
the minimum cap number this year for
aaron rodgers so they could go get some
free agents they'd be looking at a 33
million dollar cap hit next year not 17
if they trade him so that's a reason
not to do it
second second
i agree with you i think matt leflore is
caught in the crossfire between the
front office right and aaron rodgers
right and i think what's going on here
i think i think mark murphy is a genius
now
now aaron rodgers may not like the way
the genius is manifesting itself i think
mark murphy
knows exactly how to keep aaron rodgers
in the right zone of pissed off sorry
london we talked about this earlier in
the week the west welker mentality you
don't want to be too upset
you wanted to be just upset enough so
he's awesome like he was last year
just upset enough so he's motivated to
be the mvp so now they have it set up we
can let him go next year the cap charge
would be 17 million if we trade him
that's manageable relative to some of
the other cap hits we've seen it's a lot
more manageable than 33 so that's
looming so what does aaron rodgers do he
comes back and he kicks ass again and
he's the mvp again or close to it
mission accomplished for mark murphy i'm
telling you
for as smart as aaron rodgers is mark
murphy's smarter aaron rodgers is
playing chess
mark murphy's playing 3d multi-level
chess i don't know mark murphy i like
mark
i'm not buying into all that he's really
good get me wrong here's the here's
here's what he's using against aaron
rodgers right aaron rodgers obsession
with never being the bad guy with never
upsetting the fan base he's afraid to
get treated like farve did after far of
left rogers was the starting quarterback
the day that farv came back as a member
of the vikings and every time brett
favre was on the field they boot him and
boot him and boot him and boot him aaron
rodgers is trying to avoid that and i
think mark murphy understands it and you
know because you made the comment about
the possibility that aaron rodgers will
say screw it i want out of here he won't
he won't do it because he knows that
makes him public enemy number one if he
does well i you know but i think they
got to be careful here as he won't be
because this is going to be more on the
organization than brett favre scenario
would be this is going to be a little
bit like no and i think the fans will be
able to see it and go wait no this is
this is our team's fault this isn't
roger's being like brett favre and
stringing the team along or being a
little selfish like brett favre was
that's to me where it's different and
listen mark murphy guten kust i mean you
know i
before last year in the draft i mean
i've liked everything they've done and i
still like a lot that they do i just
think last year's draft was stupid okay
i don't know any other way to say it
other than that and i think what i look
at you know you can argue again like
you're saying mark murphy's smart yeah
he's he's playing 3d chess and all that
and and rogers is playing just chess or
checkers whatever whatever but i could
also sit here and go
sure you might be playing tic-tac-toe
you were in the super bowl you were in
the super bowl window with the arguably
the best quarterback in the game and you
didn't go all in on it so i could also
sit there and go no i think you were
playing tic-tac-toe or hangman on the
side and maybe rogers is playing chess i
could i could argue that side of it too
so that's where i don't know what to
feel about it you know i'm conflicted
with this whole green bay thing i have a
lot of respect in a lot of ways but that
that situation still really bothers me
and frustrates me as you know because
i'm a big aaron rodgers fan
you made the comment about the brett
favre situation being more on him and
less on the institution see rogers was
there for that
they managed to make it look like it was
on brett favre i still believe
that they went to him february of 2008
went to farve
knowing that if they pressed him for a
clear commitment yes or no up or down in
february about playing that year he
would have said no i know so they they
they knew damn well what they were doing
they were playing chess with brett favre
and brett was playing 52 pickup well
maybe right maybe but you know he had
also done that kind of stuff the three
years previous to that too oh right he
had fault he had fault leading up to it
yes but they hatched the plan i firmly
believe they hatched the plan to get him
to finally get the hell out of here do
it early and how do you get him to get
out of here right you tell him you need
it we need to know right now right now
brett you've been you've been screwing
around i almost said a different word
you've been screwing around with us for
the last four years we need to know
right now are you in and you're out well
why do you need to know right now we
just do we just do we know right now are
you in and you're out yeah and he said
well i'm out right and then then you
barricade the door with furniture and
when he shows up again and he gets out
to another team he becomes the enemy and
and and and i think that's what's got
aaron rodgers a little freaked out
frankly i don't want to overly
psychoanalyze him i'm sure but
i think i think he's looking at this
saying they screwed brett and brett
ended up being the bad guy yeah no i i
mean again i think that's why he made
the comments he made after the game it
wasn't about like you know him posing a
threat or anything like that he's just
going man i don't know this league's
crazy i don't know where the hell this
thing's gonna go
you know i think that's what he was
really referring to who knows i never
thought they'd have drafted a
quarterback last year in the draft who
knows maybe they'll trade me this year i
mean so that's what he was trying to say
maybe aaron jones won't be back i think
he was trying to say all of those things
because it's a crazy league and he was
he's seen this stuff with brett favre
like you've talked about so uh i mean
it's we're going to keep our eye on it
certainly i'm interested to see what
they're going to do in the draft here if
there's going to be anything else here
in free agency uh that they try to do to
boost the offensive side of the ball not
that they need anything major but you
know this is it's it's it's funny that
we're talking about a guy that's
still
very very awesome and we're talking like
oh they might be trying to push him out
of the door here the next year or two
bottom line bottom line
the the full restructuring to maximize
cap space this year
would have had the practical effect of
tying aaron rodgers to the packers for
two more years because it would have
made the cap charge last year too much
to bear it's just as good as getting
your next two years guaranteed right so
i think he he was probably rooting for
the full
the full reduction and signing bonus and
kick the can in voidable years and make
it as hard as possible to trade me after
this year i think he wanted that and he
didn't get it right so
and and if they had done that what would
they have they'd have a lot of other
money on hand to go out
and
sign free agents aimed at making the
team better with t.y hilton with sammy
watkins plenty of guys still on the
market that could come in and make the
team better they that that's
17 million or so 16 million that they
don't have now because they didn't do
that restructuring i'm telling you that
this is almost shakespearean the the
level of this this this fight between
rogers and murphy that has remained cold
but could go hot at any moment it's
fascinating
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports